And one of the reasons why a bar chart like this is very good at
highlighting this missing data that's strict rigidity of the chart layout.
Evenly spaced bars, with evenly spaces widths for each bar.
The only variable we're working with in this case is the height of a bar.
So if we had fairly regular and periodic data,
it becomes very apparent to a reader when a single periodic event doesn't occur.
But it would also say that this is one of the failings of
the bar chart for our data.
One fundamental reason why the bar chart in our case doesn't work is that
the x axis is an intrinsically ordered variable.
Year 1932 comes before 1933, comes before 1934, and so forth.
A bar chart is typically best suited to represent categorical data where
these might be things like labels or groups, such as a state.
For example in our case might be the country or
continent in which the World Cup was held in.
And while years could be considered discreet values.
1932 can be thought of as a category in some sense.
There's a natural order to time, which makes a bar chart suboptimal.